à midi le coup d'envoi pour terminer de
l'année jules verne
cent ans après sa mort l'écrivain est à
l'honneur notamment à nantes sa ville
natale où une exposition est organisée
qui démarre aujourd'hui et amiens où il
a vécu il n'a pas vraiment été prise au
sérieux de son vivant aujourd'hui on
reconnaît ses talents d'écrivain et de
visionnaire bien sûr geneviève moll
pascal stelletta jules verne ses
vingt-deux mille pages une soixantaine
de chefs-d'oeuvre le l'île mystérieuse à
cinq semaines en ballon du tour du monde
en 80 jours aux enfants du capitaine
grand les épopées qui ont enflammé les
imaginations jules verne ce feu vert de
monde avait l'habitude de naviguer en
baie de somme avec l'ongle de pierre
devismes et même face à la maire qu'il
adorerait il écrivait toujours sur mes
propres d'euros il bceao
il a bon banquier il écrivait il n'y
comprendrait un coup il emportait avec
lui cette écritoire et remplissez ces
petits carnets de notes et de dessins
qu'elle et nourrir céline de 1865 et
entre deux voyages en médecins hommes il
vit dans cette maison du crotoy la
solitude il y écrit quelques
chefs-d'oeuvre dont paris au 20e siècle
et vingt mille lieues sous les mers
lorsqu'ils s'installent ici il a 37 ans
il est marié à une femme fortunée
honorine qu'il a laissé à amiens avec
leur fils michel qu'il ne supporte pas
il enverra même en maison de correction
lui qu'on fait passer pour un écrivain
pour enfants
aujourd'hui encore sur derniers
descendants ne lui pardonne pas c'était
pas un homme sympathique enfin c'était
donc fermé
routinier enfermé dans son travail c'est
qu'il est obsédé par son oeuvre
le plus grand éditeur de l'époque je
vais de celles lui demande trois livres
par an pour un salaire dérisoire il le
public dans le magasin d'éducation et de
récréation en feuilleton
alors jules verne travaillent
d'arrache-pied et s'il revient à bien en
1871 c'est pour être plus proche de sa
documentation dans les bibliothèques de
la ville industrielle
son but vulgariser la science de
l'époque il est tout à fait conscient
d'inventer un genre littéraire c'est à
dire faire de la science
quelque chose qui passe dans le roman et
s'entend après sa mort il a toujours de
nouveaux lecteurs sur sa tombe
amiens nous avons trouvé la lettre d'un
petit garçon qui lui écrit monsieur
verne je voulais vous dire que je suis
votre plus grand fan
vous avez changé ma vie